foreign
[Music]
hit by an explosion a little earlier
today has warned a serious problems
Japan is scrambling to avert a looming
years old I visited India and I was
surprised to see that the power was shut
off for a few hours every single day at
the time my main concern was how do I
watch TV or how do I use the internet
when the power was off but looking back
these were the least of people's
concerns no power meant that
refrigerators couldn't be running and
that small businesses and hospitals had
to pay for generators on a daily basis
for many people living there this was
just the harsh reality of daily life
naturally you would assume that this is
only an issue in developing countries
but one developed country that's very
much facing the same issue is none other
than Japan Japan has not only had to
implement electricity saving measures
like turning down the heat and dimming
the lights but they've been experiencing
full-on blackouts the country with
internet speeds of 319 terabits per
second and that bullet trains capable of
reaching 603 kilometers per hour is
struggling to keep the lights on at
first glance you might be driven to
think that this is due to Japan's
economic situation after all it's no
secret that Japan has been facing an
economic crisis for decades they have a
debt to GDP ratio of 257 percent their
stock market hasn't made a new all-time
high in 33 years and the Japanese yen is
at 35-year lows against the US dollar
all of these would be great reasons for
Japan to cut back on power consumption
and to try to save money but their
economic crisis is ironically not the
main reason that they're also facing an
energy crisis in fact Japan would likely
be facing an energy crisis even if their
economy was booming the problem would
actually probably be worse because
people would likely consume even more
power if the economy was booming but
then if the problem isn't being able to
pay for it what is well for Japan the
problem is actually getting their hands
on electricity for decades 80 to 90
percent of of Japan's energy has been
imported for perspective only about
seven percent of America's energy is
imported this has become one of Japan's
biggest bottlenecks and despite their
best efforts they've been unable to
escape the shackles of energy dependence
but how did such an advanced and
developed country end up in a situation
where they can't even keep the lights on
taking a look back Japan's energy crisis
wasn't something that developed
overnight it's something that developed
over a century dating back to the 1800s
it all started with a man named Emperor
Meiji Who Rose to power in 1868 when he
took over much of Japan was filled with
a bunch of samurais that were constantly
in conflict with each other there wasn't
much of a society or an economy but
Emperor Meiji was determined to change
this he wanted to implement a practical
Imperial Rule and focus on economic
growth and Enlightenment one of the
first things he did was abolish Japanese
domains which were basically the Estates
of super powerful landlords within the
Empire instead he gave these powerful
landlords positions as Governors within
the new Empire Emperor meijiya also
moved the eliminated clashes between
various armies and clans he emerged all
the armies into one Japanese military
and mandated that all Japanese men must
serve at least four years in the armed
forces he figured that fighting side by
side would help them put aside their
differences and work together and he was
right the entire area became more united
than ever and a capitalistic ideologies
were starting to spread Emperor Meiji
even went as far as establishing a
National Assembly and allowed Japanese
citizens to vote clearly even though
Meiji was an emperor by name he wasn't
what you would normally associate with
Emperors he wasn't a power hungry man
that was only concerned about increasing
his own wealth and well-being no he
truly wanted to revolutionize Japan and
to make the Empire a force to be
reckoned with but while Meiji had all of
these crazy Ambitions there was one
thing that he was never willing to do
which was give up Japanese Independence
whether that be political Independence
or energy Independence this did not mean
that he blocked out the West altogether
though he was very much willing to
listen to their ideas and to take their
advice but he wanted all growth to
originate from Japan itself and that's
exactly what happened as the textile and
railroad Industries grew so did the core
production history during meiji's Reign
Japan's silk exports Grew From 646 tons
to 9462 tons but their core production
grew even more from 0.66 million tons to
23.5 million tons by the time Emperor
Meiji died in 1912 the Japanese empire
had become the most developed nation in
East Asia and that this kind of got to
their head they would provoke the United
States by bombing Pearl Harbor and that
didn't really end all that well for them
by the end of World War II Japan was
devastated and occupied by Americans but
while Japan may have been physically
destroyed their spirit and pride was
still very much intact they may have
lost the conquest War but they sure as
hell weren't gonna lose the economic war
and fortunately for them the West was
very much on their side having
capitalistic success stories in the East
with the Japan and South Korea Ria was
very much important for the west and
their war against socialist China and
the USSR so the West supported Japan all
the way and before you knew it the
country was booming but there was one
minor issue Japan's natural resources
could not keep up with the
west-supported steroid growth if this
was during regular times Japan had
probably would have considered more
sustainable options but tensions were
high with the Cold War and Japan had way
too much to prove so in 1960 the
Japanese government allowed imported oil
to compete with the domestic Cola as a
prime source of energy and at this
marked the beginning of Japan's energy
dependence
foreign
throughout the 1960s Japan would
experience some of the most explosive
economic growth numbers ever recorded
their energy dependence also skyrocketed
from 42 to over 90 percent but very few
people saw this as a problem many people
actually saw this as an advantage you
see a Japanese core production was
extremely expensive relative to the US
and Europe due to poor mining conditions
so importing oil from Middle Eastern
countries not only saw the Japan's
energy bottleneck but it also reduced
Energy prices substantially at first
this seemed like a win-win scenario up
until 1973 when Japan first witnessed
the horrors of energy dependence this
year OPEC would introduce an oil embargo
against the US and all of their allies
which of course included Japan with
Rising tensions regarding Israel Japan
and Europe knew that this could be a
possibility and that that's why they
stocked up on oil before the Embargo but
even with that oil prices in Japan grew
four to five fold for perspective the
gas price went up that we saw earlier
this year was barely at 2x from the lows
fortunately this oil embargo will only
lasted about five months but Japan was
very much scarred for life and their
tone regarding economic growth flipped
on its head from maximizing growth no
matter what to just achieving moderate
sustainable growth but this would turn
out to be nearly impossible the energy
consumption of Japan had become so large
that there was no way for the country to
support themselves based on traditional
fuel sources like oil and coal so they
had to think outside the box and to
brainstorm newer methods of energy
generation and what they landed on was
nuclear power Japan had already doubled
with the nuclear power in the past
having opened their first plant in 1966
but after 1973 expanding nuclear power
generation became their number one
priority this was by no means a fast
process but Japan was determined they
consistently opened one plant after
another and within the next 20 years
Japan was able to grow the nuclear power
generation from 3000 megawatts to 43 000
megawatts this brought down their energy
dependence from over 90 percent down to
78 percent there was obviously still a
long way to go and a full-on transition
would likely take a century but Japan
was committed and persistent for them
this wasn't no longer a matter of just
keeping Energy prices low it was a
matter of maintaining economic and
political autonomy you know and never a
good thing when a foreign power can pull
the plug on your entire country but all
of this progress would be stopped at
dead in its tracks in 2011. this year
Japan would experience the worst
earthquake they ever recorded which
caused the tsunami as well the nuclear
power plants would automatically shut
down as soon as it detected the
earthquake but the subsequent tsunami
would flood the Fukushima planned and
the lead to Radioactive contamination
over the next few days 110
000 people had to be evacuated from
nearby areas and the Fukushima disaster
is ranked as the second worst nuclear
disaster in history only beaten out by
Chernobyl I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that public sentiment
turned strongly against nuclear power
following this incident and with all
this opposition Japan had no choice but
to shut down their remaining plans
making them more energy dependent than
ever
foreign
energy dependence of well over 90
percent it's not surprising that Japan
has to deal with conserving power and
the blackouts despite being a developed
country Japan hasn't quit trying to
become self-sustainable though they've
hatched up a new idea involving hydrogen
instead of nuclear power it turns out
that while Japan doesn't have a much
coal or oil they have a bunch of
hydrogen the ocean floor surrounding
Japan are filled with it this is by no
means a new discovery the reason that
these reserves weren't already leveraged
was due to technological limitations you
see it the ocean floors aren't filled
with hydrogen itself they're actually
filled with a sherbet-like substance
that's often referred to it as fire ice
to extract this fire eyes you first have
to Voyage deep into the ocean where the
depth is over a thousand meters or
nearly 3 300 feet from there you have to
drill hundreds of meters into the sea
floor to actually extract the fire ice
it's not not just plug and play from
there either you then have to extract
the methane inside the fire ice and then
convert it to hydrogen on the bright
side each cubic meter of methane hydrate
is able to produce 160 cubic meters of
methane gas which can then be converted
to hydrogen so you definitely get a
bunch of bang for your buck but that
doesn't make it any easier to extract
the Japanese have been working on a new
drilling method that can transport the
fire eyes through underwater pipelines
directly to Japan but that's still very
much in the beta phases of development
figuring all of this out is only half
the battle though the second half is
actually getting people to use it it
looks like they've definitely got
Japanese companies on board given that
Toyota Honda and the Nissan are all
working on hydrogen vehicles but it's
not clear if Japanese citizens will
actually choose these offerings over
traditional EVS especially given that
hydrogen vehicles and hydrogen itself is
rather expensive fortunately Japan isn't
betting at all on hydrogen they were
very much working on bringing back
nuclear power given that it's been over
a decade since the Fukushima nuclear
disaster tensions have significantly
cooled down and the public has become
much more open to the idea of nuclear
power especially when they see the
blackouts firsthand with winter around
the corner in the northern hemisphere
people are likely going to turn up
heaters which will only worsen the issue
this is why Japan's prime minister is
pushing to reopen as many as nine
nuclear reactors this winter but while
that could help with getting through the
winter Japan will still very much be in
an energy crunch for the foreseeable
future and that's why Japan is
struggling to keep the lights on bu
supported nuclear energy in Japan
scenario comment that down below also
drop a like if you hope that Japan
figures something out for the sake of
their citizens and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one